names Max Lombardi and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about it the Lombardi tails
[Music]
let me tell you about reality benders
first off we like to call Bixby's y1 in
case someone accidentally says something
in front of a civilian it don't tip them
off to if you're talking to a reality
bender they may not know all they can do
and you don't want to give them any
ideas these [ __ ] are dangerous you
see one you don't engage unless you
absolutely have to if you do have to be
polite try to think happy thoughts maybe
I'll have a good day
probably not whenever you can let the
experts deal with them we don't try
containing them most of the time yeah
the foundation don't usually work that
way but we like to have a world to live
in so on this point we usually agree
with the GOC they're better gone ok so
you're fighting someone who can pretty
much do anything how do you stop well
first off they can't do anything they
ain't thought of like maybe they can all
read minds but if they ain't thought
about doing it don't know they can then
they're not gonna try it remember
they're not smarter than you they may be
able to do different things might know
things you don't but they're not smarter
second they got a concentrate we had one
[ __ ] he decided he was gonna know
about everybody watching him [ __ ]
killed 20 of us before he had just a
bunch of us Russian couldn't get all of
us you know which kind of Bixby's are
the worst depends how you mean for my
money it's a kid Bixby almost always
ends with a bullet sniper can usually
take him out pretty easy but actually
killing them you show me a guy who just
shot a three-year-old I show you
somebody with some damage upstairs there
are worse things you'll do for the
foundation
but not a lot now hardest to take down
usually someone around late teens early
20s much younger they don't know how to
do as much harm older than that Bank got
much flexibility and they're thinking to
try anything real up there late teens
early 20s they're gonna experiment
they're gonna try anything that springs
to mind they're not gonna be slow and
careful and figuring out what they can
do we get one of them we pull out the
big guns now it don't always end with us
killing sometimes especially the older
ones we can talk with them a little
convince them the world ain't worth get
them to move on somewhere else a lot of
them will even do it on their own so far
may one of them ever came back no one
knows why
maybe this world is really that much of
a [ __ ] or maybe someone's eaten them
I don't know anyway now you see what I
mean what I say a giant turtle ain't no
big deal even if it is spitting fire at
us